can you hear me now no yes okay good
thank you the last battle actually has
set up our discussion of this last panel
of the day very nicely because the
general subject of our papers is
essentially the intersection in the
narratives of the state about itself and
about the nation with architectural
practice there's one paper which won't
be presented which was advertised and it
was the paper by bethlo sat though was
coming from Chile and unfortunately he
can't join us because of course he's
remained there collaborating with
reconstruction efforts after the
earthquake that hit this past februari
so his paper which I can only mention
very schematically here examined
actually architectures functions of
political proclamation and symbolism
discourse in the context of military
regime of general pages he minutes in
1950s and as well a very understudied in
very interesting context now but
interestingly by showcasing architecture
as proof of the success of a program of
national modernization and framing it
within the boundaries of a lot of
narratives we've seen hovering over many
papers those of progress and so on the
media apparatus of the state brandished
very paradigmatic examples of modern
architecture as in the language of the
day as a permanent almost violence hard
evidence politics so there was a
transfer mutual translation between the
language of politics and political
statements and the actual presence of
monuments which is a very interesting
question that everyone I think wrestles
with and yet the politics of these
spaces went far beyond this symbolic
level a point which was just brought up
a few minutes ago because Santos
analysis also show that architectures
complicity with our with authoritarian
practices went beyond that to the
rituals to the sort of deserving as a
stage for the rituals of power as well
and also serving as a device of social
containment so there were many levels
and many layers of to examine there and
of course the rest of our papers and our
session will focus and architectures
compromise relationship to these claims
in these kinds of statements in the case
of three other mid 20th century states
and in every case we'll see a very
interesting dialogue in which
architectural production and the state's
narrative
means if we could call him that came to
or come to contain inhabit and even
confuse one another very productively um
I'm going to introduce the speakers in
order of appearance ascencion the
Atlantis received her PhD from the
department of art history at the
University of Saragossa where she now
teaches architectural history and theory
and her papers titled the architecture
of the state the dictatorship of general
Franco in Spain in the 40s and 50s
Ashley dough is a practicing architect
who has received degrees from Iowa State
University in princeton and is currently
in the HTC program at MIT finishing a
Masters of Science and architecture
research degree and his papers titled it
was titled whose war so modernizing
development and historic restoration on
the same side of socialism and now has
intriguingly changed and it's called
recomposing warsaw modernizing
development and historic restoration on
the same side of socialism that part has
not changed which was just interesting
now our last speaker would be Federico
frisky who received his PhD in history
of art from the University of the and
I'm going to butcher the name but it's
called the vid butter strand in
Johannesburg where he's currently a
senior lecturer at the wit School of
Arts and his paper is titled Bora
brutalism africana nationalism
architecture and the imaginary of high
culture 1948 through 76 and also since
we're also introducing kind of
extracurricular talents of our speakers
for that eco I have just learned by
googling him is a very gifted opera
singer as well as an artist story so
since young goes first thank
in good afternoon and first of all
thanks to the organist organizers for
lettin me is speaking to my presentation
and I hope my Spanish accent is under
stable to everybody if not a place for
it well welcome to the Spanish Spanish
architect under Frank Weems Frank Olson
and this papers focus in the different
instruments used by Franco to control a
the architecture masakit ly 3 I read it
administrative system second the use of
media and third the use of architectural
exhibitions from the outset the Franco
regime was determined to present a
united front which was to profoundly
affect not only architecture on which
the dictatorship beast out hide symbolic
value but also all other spheres of a
Spanish society this attempt however
proved to be more root in fiction than
in fact as a national architectural
style never really materialized
materialized despite the tight control
will did by state bodies such as the
central authority on architecture and
the central 30 on devastated regions and
restoration this centralized and direct
hierarchical organizations were
responsible for overseeing the
reconstruction of citizen towns
destroyed during the civil war and for
monitoring the work of architects in
line with this one of the first test
tasks to be carried out by these two
institutions was a purge of all
professionals related in any way to the
republican government in 1940 any
professional who had maintained
relations or who had held a professional
position in connection to the government
of the Second Republic was persecuted
this sanctions were enforced the
following year when a huge number of
Spanish architects were temporarily or
permanently disqualifying some of whom
have already been exiled as in the case
of casa
sir I won't sign many other modernist
professionals such as Fernando Garcia
Merkel al or Leopoldo Torres vulvas
others such as Fernando Chaka I over
Alejandro foreign we're disqualified for
a number of years and were later on able
to practice their profession once the
porch have been carry out on the
architectural body architectural
practice was chiefly monitored when it
came to devastate radians for example
the pro yes had to go through the
sovereign approval processes first of
all at a local level the regional
offices and then at the national level
not forgetting to mention the control
exercised by the chief architects when
they periodically visited the various
work in progress having the architects
under control the dictators the
dictatorship used every available means
to regulate and manage the architectural
falsin styles that would best press the
spirit of the nation's new era the media
particularly specialized as magazines as
the construction or rev istana finale
arquitectura was used to give a platform
to architects connected to the regime
from which they disseminate a
conservative aesthetic ideology
signifying a regression with regard to
the model falls introduced it to Spain
in the light 20s and 30s the rejection
of rationalist architecture was due to
the homogeneous style that was
associated with a modern movement
athleta sees that was indeed prevalent
in other countries yet in Spain this
rejection took on a political dimension
as a rationalist architecture was linked
it to the Second Republic moreover the
return to hysteresis that Spanish
architecture was rejected to under
Franco was bolstered by specific factors
in our country firstly the existence of
a powerful story since the school of
thought that had been investigating the
existence of a national architecture
since the end of the 19th century this
ten
she became a trend breann alyse
architecture in the opening the case of
the 20th century and didn't disappear
with the emergency of rationalist
architecture consequently when the
political context a dictatorship
interested in creating its own mythology
of spain's history allow it for it this
history things that had never entirely
disappear gained renewing strength
secondly given the dire economic stress
Spain was faced with at the end of the
Civil War which considered with the
beginning of the Second World War and
it's ever difficulty of getting basic
materials bitter to constructions such
as cement and iron into the country the
logical conclusion was for the
architects to go back to using
traditional materials and construction
techniques which we are tripping and
easier to obtain at that time this fat
link with the previous increasing
interest for the popular architecture in
the twenties as a studies as publication
of several architects made evident
significantly know all this is that
virtue was made of necessity the
argument being that this architectural
reorientation reaction of contemporary
materials and the return to traditional
ones was in defiance of local styles the
central authority on devastated regions
and restoration was not only one of the
most active institution is trailing this
idea the effects of of it worse of its
sorry work was soon felt having a
decisive influence on the transformation
of the rural world's fistula me through
the efforts of this organization of
different 90 41 to negativity in 1957 a
pre firmly traditionals and nationalist
aesthetic was born that did however
including it in its detail decorator the
characteristics of each region so as to
avoid the homogeneity attributed to
rationalist are
these new terms in spite of their
regional differences had aspects in
common which enable us to identify the
devastated regions style this town or
village where i enclose ridley Organa
side in two orthogonal frameworks where
the public space of the square
represents the regime's social and
political order surrounded as it as it
is by the church the town council and
the barrack house of the world Fe be in
order in other words buildings that
represent religious political and
military power respectively these
buildings are in town surrounded by the
formal houses arranged it according to
type and category and the exterior urban
profile of the town is also taking into
account it in it design where the bulk
of the church at acts as a reference
point and stands out above all other
buildings forming the village silhouette
furthermore all these buildings will be
the public architecture rural housing
and spite of elements particular to each
rayon have similarities in terms of the
architectural force used they are modest
modest in size of one or two floors have
tiled roofs signal in a rejection of the
flat roof associated with a modern
architectural movement display simple
modular design repeated on house town
council church a birdhouse where
doorways balconies eaves are reiterated
in fact according to the experts some
buildings exhibit a certain resemblance
to architectural models or
cinematography cinematographic ille sets
this devastated Regency style can undock
be considered one of the most
significant contributions of that time
as well as being a peculiarity that sets
Spain apart from other contemporary
dictatorships despite the fact that the
interests in the rural world and
indigenous materials also was very
present in Italia under the Mussolini
dictatorships compared to problems and
difficulties in building fascist
architecture in towns the effects of
Franco seems was felt above all out of
big cities and especially in rural areas
given that the needs of reconstruction
so many destroyed village was the
provided second sir concerns for
Franco's regime to model the reality to
his state's producing a real Franco
landscape still perceived thurs for
current Spanish society this is probably
the only field in which the most
effective control on architecture by
Hispanic tatto ship was produced Franco
like the other European dictators was
highly aware of the importance of the
role of propaganda and indoctrination
and control of the population and
architecture to which the regime granted
special significance it wasn't screwed
from this reel of thought in the
regulation to the topic we are examining
we have noted the existence of a
purposeful propaganda machine
incorporating the daily press who
planted reported the country's
reconstruction process and the important
role Franco played in this section so
there are frequent articles in this vein
from the prayers of the tongue outlining
Franco's numerals and regular visits to
a narration of wars and restoration of
monuments there were also however
specialist eyes magazines such a
reconstruction recollection or register
a failed arquitectura who catered for a
limited section of the population the
architects this monthly
or bimonthly magazines effective fulfill
several aims to build up an official
image of franchising and to consolidate
an architectural aesthetic not a trivial
matter when we take into account that
after the war Spain was isolated and
architects many of whom where Jonah
recently graduated from architectural
schools had no access to other means of
information in this respect these
magazines were the main point of
reference for architects to the extent
that the buildings owned in them serve
it as a feedback system reinforcing the
architectural criteria professionals who
were in the service of the state in the
relay in relation to the first aspect
construction the official image of the
regime these magazines acted in parallel
with the rest of the national press
which was also totally controlled by the
dictatorship in presenting a Manichean
version of the Civil War and the
Republic's government where the idea of
Franco's leader and savior of the
homeland was reinforced both publication
published numerous articles presenting a
simple am by and biased or prejudiced
vision of the recent past reducing it to
the dichotomy of pass Republicans
destruction and present Franco's regime
reconstruction these magazines also
provide descriptions of gold ruins
particularly through through the forest
referring to the destruction of temple
charts combat in quasi apocalyptical
turns using and abusing words like
heroes rings of our glorious crusade to
confront the destructive power of mercy
since the enterprising capability of the
regime with Frank wat his head emerged
it involve constructing an official
story that will legitimize the new order
whereby monuments destroyed by the
Republicans and subsequently restored by
Franco's regime will come to represent
the quality of the
symbols of chains produced in our
country the new Frank with the state
considered these monuments to be living
in fragments of a Spain's history that
signed their glory in the eternal
language of a stone which is why they
attach attach so much importance to them
and why the restoration was given such
attention in so many of the magazine's
pages the case of male cheetah an
important village due to the fat that
son of the largest and most bloody
battles during the Civil War hot sake
implicit place in this locality is
particular significant in terms of the
symbolic value at the regime attributed
to ruins Bell cheated that Marcia sprays
it and that Franco's Spain rebel and
given that Bell chetan this is a
particular fat in Spain was one of the
first localities to be adopted by Franco
who made an unusual decision next to her
the reconstruction of a Newton it would
say to let to live sorry to leave the
ruins of the old town as a permanent
reminder of the war and by the same
equation as a homemade to the heroes in
Franco's troops sir it is also worth
mentioning in relation to magazines
certain aspects as it is surprising that
soon after the Civil War two magazines
reconstruction and released another
album detector ax with such a costly
format should be published in a country
in mercy in a normal economic economic
difficulties meticulous design a large
number of image large format and quality
paper are some son of the
characteristics that give a spouse for
thought especially we consider that this
publication we are designing for a
minority readerships the architects all
of these let's let Lissa to suppose that
apart from being instrument in
controlling and education the taste of
architects the details of this magazine
so far anonymous because no editor's
name
beer we're aware that they were writing
a new chapter in Spain's history and
that this publication will provide
documentary evidence on that fat which
is why they paid such great attention to
the task at hand in fact now the
researchers we are consulting on all
these special SI reviews and with my
third arguments about architectural
exhibitions the regime's attempt to
control architecture was apparent in
another no less important aspect
particularly from the pure point of view
of symbolic and ideological values this
being the construction of a propaganda
apparatus surrounding the figure of the
dictator representing him as the leader
are two important Spanish heroic figures
who saved the homeland from the
destruction caused by the Second
Republic an image that was in keeping
with that other of other dictators of
that time such as Hitler Mussolini or
Stalin in this context it should be
analyzed another notable phenomenon for
that area the proliferation of
architectural exhibition about the
reconstruction of the country this
events organized by the central
authority on devastated regions were
held in barrio Spanish capital cities to
show the world undertaken throughout the
forest the aim of all these activities
was to realize highlight and strengthen
the leaders rule before the Society of
that time obviously this is the first
exhibition in 94 a little work could be
some as the devastated Raiders had only
been in operation for a short time so
the organizers decided to present a
sample of the projects to be carried out
by the institution house in what is
currently now the national labor in
Spain the photographs from the
exhibition so 14 rooms that demonstrate
the remarkable effort poor put into the
world such as the construction of
temporary sets an altar to the Fallen
wall painting
fresco or destruction that echoed the
monumental style of Italian paintings
from 30s and as so we're most logical
presentation plants and models of the
reconstruction projects in the village
adopted by the caudillo the organizers
interest in so in the figure of the cal
do as the country's protector should be
emphasized hence his boost appears frame
it by a large allegorical mural
representing the National reconstruction
and the opening ceremony on june the
1494 II was preceded over by Franco
perched on a medieval-style from a
crucial at his fists feet reinforcing
the idea of the dictator as a monarch
the subsequent exhibition held in 1945
in San Sebastian and in 1948 in n
scibilia display however an overwhelming
amount of models photos and plans of
numerals or constructive village
evidence of the effectiveness with which
the state had carry out the task
likewise it is worth reliving a joint ex
officio health in 1941 we are
contemporary German architecture was
sewn to emphasize Franco's close
relationship with Hitler alongside a
Spanish architecture this exhibition
held in the Palacio del retiro de Madrid
presented models of some of the most
important projects for the latent for
the regime el proyecto Morales kaiidas
as a way of expressing the new style in
posted by the dictatorship the aim of
the of these public events was to show
and emphasize the country's recovery
through the reconstruction of house in
infrastructure and monuments hence the
grid symbolical symbolic importance paid
to architecture and cultural heritage in
personifying the new spirit sweeping the
nation this type of xev
where our part of the comprehensive
propaganda apparatus the dictatorship
had put in place in order to establish
the new regime the level of importance
the dictatorship afforded it this type
of events and activities list us to
surmise that in was perhaps measuring
itself up up to I confronting the memory
or the ghost of the republican
government it should not be forgotten
that the second spanish republic had
remain anchored in the collective
consciousness not only as a political a
politically turbulent of turbulent files
but also as a period when culture three
earning the nickname in the body of
historical iterator the Silver Age those
faced with active control lighting of
the thirties Franco's dictatorship
introduced a surprising program of
cultural activities and propaganda at
focused around the dictator which were
intended to invalidate that sparkle from
the recent past associated with the
republican government and reinforce
control over the population a large
session of which had been in favor of
the Republic through the incessant
repetition of the new national values
that is very all the seventh also this
is only speculation on my part it does
seem as it for if Franco's government
was contemplating and construction its
image through this architectural
reservation in reaction to that of the
republican government one of whose major
symbol as all of we know was the
construction of the grid and brilliant
pavilion of the Spanish Republic for the
Paris international exhibition of 1937
in conclusion the regime's promotion of
hysteresis force and style was inducted
of Greater consequence during the
forests in terms of public architecture
as well as in the rest
relation of monuments as demonstrated by
the regular return to the structure
original phase of over the obligatory
medieval medieval ization of buildings
mrs. anak an astonishing assemble
because the el rincon de Goya is one of
the key word from the first period
spanish rationalist architecture and it
was transformed it into other thing okay
so and by entire towns they are a bonus
money feat municipality of sauce delray
catlica catlico is a prime example of
this i invite you to visit this
beautiful town it lies lies lies like a
middle-aged is it not it's a fixed e60
what is beautiful in fact and but in the
field of creative New York detector
contemporary Spanish architecture ended
up returning to its place in the modern
sphere exposing the regime's
contradictions and lack of consistency
in this field several fads revealed this
to be the case in the name in the
fifties particularly when it came to
privately found it architecture some
work managed to avoid their regimes
aesthetic control and demonstrate the
influence of international artists what
is most Vash 19 in this instance is this
the assimilation of organic of organic
architecture in categories interesante
as interesting as cinema and theaters
here are examples of mine town by intra
gathi it is even more surprising that
john architects in the state's service
accomplished project's budget on
regional architecture did far removed
from the pictorial snacks of son of the
towns built by the central authority on
devastated regions where they explored
the possibility of using more astra and
modern more model designs as
demonstrated in the style of the era
cultural school in Talavera de la reina
by raphael aborto other science of
chains were apparent in public
architecture were already towards the
end of the 40's buildings were different
in style to the story things promoted by
Regine were constructed such as the casa
sin decal by Cabrera on oberto in madrid
last lit and more so presently Franco's
regime itself having a band on it that
his dreams of glory and unity choose
modern architecture to represent the
country's official architecture abroad
something which is very significant in
that way we are referring to the Spanish
be as a billion designed by the
architect skoura listen Molly soon for
the bruselas international division of
1958 a word that disturbed Lee won the
first international prayer price in this
division alight and modern construction
completely different from these
tortoises defended by the regime not
long before this to conclude the
cooperation between the models has
posted at the exhibition of works by the
central authority on architecture in
mobility 94 e 1 and the image from
magazines the town of the Spanish
Pavilion in Brussels in 1958 separated
by the time frame of Holy 70 years so
they in consists the inconsistency in
Spanish fascist architecture and the
fertility of the rainiest a4 to control
a reality that eventually turn it
against the dictators own dreams thanks
to you for listening
I guess why that is loading I would like
to take this opportunity to thank the
organizers for putting this amazing
conference together and also for Lewis
for providing insightful and productive
comments which thankfully for your
benefit condensed a 40 page paper to
2,400 words so thanks for those comments
and also to there's going to be a voting
on which title was better whose Warsaw
recomposing Warsaw so just keep that in
mind on October 17th 1945 the heart of
composer Frederic Chopin was returned
from safekeeping in a farmhouse during
the Nazi occupation of Poland to its
reliquary in the church of the holy
cross while the heart of poland may have
been returned to warsaw the recovery in
the aftermath of World War two would
take generations of effort the
reconstitution of Poland in the early
twentieth centuries fuel destructive
nationalists animosities on both sides
of the reconstituted state and the
internal interwar divisions of
parliamentary governance further
complicate these narratives in addition
to these political conditions
industrialization its requisite
population movement to urban centers and
the attendant economic stratification
impacted the development of the Polish
nation both in its partitioned and
modern incarnations the massive
devastation wrought by World War two
exact at a heavy toll on Poland with the
city of Warsaw in particular as roughly
eighty five percent of the city was
destroyed the following paper
demonstrates two aspects of the Warsaw
reconstruction not through the
examination of physical reconstruction
itself but through the investigation how
reconstruction was represented in a
sequence of four publications which were
translated into English from 1946 to
nineteen sixty-four the first aspect of
this paper is to challenge the
perception of restoration is being
opposed with the concept of
modernization the former is often
considered as a means to hold true
tradition fixing artifacts within a time
frame and while the latter is construed
as a material advancement and societal
progress polish architects and
politicians
reconstruction of Warsaw is synonymous
with the industrial development of the
state in a modern sense restoration and
modernization were considered one in the
same the second aspect is that
restoration in the context of Warsaw in
particular was deployed by a new
socialist state as a vehicle for
legitimizing their authority and
possibly as a latent means to resist by
segments of the Polish population to
resist the full imposition of an
external ideological system this paper
will consider for publications the first
reconstruction exhibition pamphlet from
1946 entitled Warsaw lives again with an
introduction by Lewis Mumford and
written by stanislav erect the second is
a presidential speech by bola saw Beirut
given a 1949 that published in nineteen
fifty packaged and published as the
pictorial essay the six-year plan for
the reconstruction of Warsaw the third
is a site-specific history of the old
town of Warsaw produced in 1956 by
jean-jacques owatta wits and P entry
baginski and the final is a
retrospective narrative by one of the
architects of reconstruction at el cielo
whiskey that appeared in 1964 titled
Warsaw a city destroyed and rebuilt what
this paper intends to demonstrate by
relating these texts is a coherence
beyond ideology that posits historic
restoration and modern development as
similar methods towards societal
progress an image of progress that
served the interests of an occupier so
we see here the sequence of texts Warsaw
lives again of followed by the
president's speech and then this
anthology of the reconstruction and then
the narrative from the 1960s the
bundling of architectural preservation
and modernist mandates a societal
remediation begin early in
reconstruction efforts as in july of
1946 edward streets Liske the deputy
mayor of warsaw defines the primary
motive of the reconstruction plan is to
quote preserve the city's characteristic
outlines its former architectural
profile and quote while simultaneously
attempting to prevent the crowding which
prevailed so widely this coupling is
carried through party rhetoric and is
evidenced by these subsequent
publications implemented through urban
planning policies contemporaneous with
these statements by
civic establishment the introduction by
Lewis Mumford and Warsaw olives again
declares that quote Warsaw will live
again not by a pious restoration of the
past not by idolizing it's dead self but
by taking leadership in building a new
kind of urban community end quote the
photo essay contained beyond this
preface closes with the preliminary City
diagram which specifies sections of the
city and their mono programme
designation within the larger
reconstruction plan the urban diagram is
faced by a collage of an aerial view of
Warsaw ruins overlaid with models of
reconstruction the final image is
construed as a critique of the past
capital structure but destruction
provided an opportunity to rebuild a new
and modern way of life modern on the
socialist system adjustments to the city
and by extension society would have
grounding in the history of Warsaw but
could only be advanced and calibrated
through socialist modernizing quote in
so designing the city-state celebrex the
planners are aware that their plans will
affect perhaps for many years to come
the social structure of the country
unquote so we see here the kind of
typical specific sections of the city
outlined and then the aerial ruins of
Warsaw overlaid with modern models the
diagrammatic representation of the city
would gain further currency and the
published pictorial record of bolas
lobby routes opening speech given at the
warsaw conference of the polish united
workers party on july 3rd 1949 the book
opens with a photograph of bare root off
to the left of the image and the
requisite committee seated behind him
above the party panel a large map of
Warsaw dominates the center of the image
this map provided an interactive surface
that would illuminate specific sections
is the president spoke of architectural
restoration housing infrastructure and
industrial projects biruta states that
reconstruction has entered a second
period of planning different from that
just after the war and which
extraordinary spontaneity coupled with a
large number of carefully planned
undertakings saw to expediently
resurrect the city he states quote we
must see to it that the class struggle
is suitably reflected in the execution
of every undertaking
quote how this image and association
which we grafted onto replicas of
medieval streetscapes and baroque
palaces fell to the preservationist
planners and of course to party rhetoric
so we see here here's the large map and
then these two would have appeared
underneath it in the publication and so
you can see the streets being
illuminated various levels of
infrastructure and then these segments
of the city as he spoke about different
sections and then here we have Beirut
speaking and then for those of you
scoring along at home our friend Joseph
Stalin who was also very much thanked in
the course of this document so you
understand those external conditions the
reconstruction history Janza kuwata wits
and ph urban jency published in 1956
sketches the rebuilding of warsaw's old
town this text offers more insight to
the bureaucratic mechanisms of
reconstruction as shortly after the
silver Sylvia liberation in january of
1945 the bureau for the reconstruction
of warsaw the BOS was established and
worked in tandem with the Department of
historic architecture an agency that was
charged with the protection and
rebuilding of historic structures the
authors declared the reconstruction as
being the first of its kind in history
however Warsaw is also compared with the
past destructions of Babylon in
Jerusalem the utilization of existing
roads and subterranean infrastructure
was deemed the most effective means to
rapidly reconstruct the city the
foundation bolts first floors of the
buildings of the old town had survived
for the most part and redeemed suitable
basis for reconstruction the old town
was we returned to a residential quarter
in keeping with the larger master plan
quote it only remained to decide upon
the style of reconstruction and to solve
the problem of back to the old town to
modern housing conditions end quote the
destruction of the old town revealed
various stages of building methods and
the center of Warsaw was considered a
vast research laboratory the metaphor of
the laboratory is a deliberate situation
of architectural restoration within a
modern development strategy as craftsmen
we're working alongside specialized
professions houses which lent themselves
residences of course regain this
function the exteriors returned to a
historical image but the common spaces
such as stairwells were altered to
provide more habitable space and modern
many's the larger patrician period
structures considered the most important
and conducive to housing cultural
institutions such as the Warsaw History
Museum were to be restored throughout
the plans were also connected to the
construction of the major highway artery
of the east-west thoroughfare which
tunneled under the city tunneling new
infrastructure below while restoring
structures above is not new unique to
Poland but how the two were framed
within the rubrics of central
bureaucracy government sanction and
ideological legitimacy is productively
specific to our conversation and so we
see here this is the east-west
thoroughfare which was tunneled under
the old section of the city and this was
a series of drawings of four elevations
throughout the whole section of the old
town and even the new town in which
wartime devastation was juxtaposed with
the images before the war and then how
the buildings were subsequently restored
in 1964 it also whiskey published a
retrospective that documented the 19
years of rebuilding since the liberation
war saw a city destroyed and rebuilt
begins in October 1944 after the Nazis
had crushed the Warsaw Uprising he then
flashes to nineteen sixty situating the
text not from the point of the quote
reconstruction of Warsaw but from the
construction of Warsaw end quote and we
see right there his emphatic boldness of
that assertion citing the Lange the
first cornerstone which occurred on
january of 1945 he contrasts this
founding with the modernist projects of
Shonda Garen Brasilia he states that
these cities began from a similar
cornerstone but that Warsaw was at urban
spirit before it was a ruin and that
spirit is what brought the survivors and
the socialists back to found the city
again zebra whiskey positions the clean
site conception of capital cities being
constructed under Western auspices as
distinct from the socialist approach for
Warsaw which he claims nurtures history
while actively modernizing
with the consolidation of socialist
power in 1947 it was the year of two
major organizational changes the vos was
restructured and renamed the Warsaw town
planning office with oversight by the
City Council and the government
Commissioner for Warsaw reconstruction
was created within the ministry of
reconstruction at dealt nationally the
Commissioner was charged with management
of all departments and allocation of
financial resources dealing with the
reconstruction of the city during the
early years of reconstruction funding
originated from a variety of sources
such as private individuals social
organizations and the state under the
new structure most of the money the
profit from nationalized industries was
to be allocated by the state for
reinvestment in further
industrialization and then the
subsequent erection of housing 1947 also
witnessed the consolidation of the
construction efforts into cooperative
and state contractor's with a single
division specializing in the
reconstruction of historical buildings
quote among the staff it employs our
highly skilled craftsmen Mason's
plasterers ironsmith sitters bricklayers
masters of their craft they have
restored Warsaw's old town and new town
with artistry rarely if ever found in
the large-scale building of modern times
end quote this condition situates the
reconstruction of the old town squarely
within the confines of a modern
development project and the placement of
craftsmen among the ranks of the
construction conglomerate further places
modernization and restoration on an
equal footing throughout Suber whiskies
book the responsible management of
finances coupled with effective
construction organization is authentic
by the promoted ability of socialism to
negotiate the scales of urban planning
alongside the particularity of
historical architecture so we see here
as super whiskey often did contrasting
you know wartime devastation with what
was built and you'll see in these two
plans that a lot of the eighteenth and
nineteenth century additions that had
gone on had been built were removed from
the reconstruction plans and we'll go
into that here in a little bit too risky
recounts the main principles of the
reconstruction plan of which point 12
declares that quote all the barbers who
destroyed monuments of the past relics
the material and cultural progress of
the nation are to be restored the
reconstituted old town and other relics
will demonstrate in coming
generations the historic forms of Polish
architecture at the same time they
should be adapted to suit modern ways of
living end quote the following lines
present a very clear and distinct
relation of historic restoration to
ideological projection and while
providing potential resistance to it
quote for after all of our souviens one
of their own city restored and not a new
anonymous city the traditionally archaic
nature of the historic section is no
accident on the contrary it is a welcome
effect of conscious effect by town
planners who from the very first
blueprints of the new Warsaw insisted on
reconstructing the old town end quote
all of the texts decry the crimes of
Nazi occupation which deliberately
targeted artifacts of Polish history and
subjects of national culture a condition
augmented according to these authors by
the destructive effects of almost two
centuries of capitalist building the
eighteenth and nineteenth centuries were
regarded as the period consumed by the
capitalist ascendancy much to the
detriment of the worker Albrecht in
seara whiskey both condemned the chaotic
economic social life and the obsolescent
nineteenth century buildings that
emerged while Beirut states quote in
this confused chase after profits the
dominating feature for dozens of years
architectural values inherited from
bygone centuries vanished this unique
architecture of the Vistula escarpment
and others were lost the burial of
national architectural heritage by
profit driven balance sheets justified
the actions of socialist recovery
efforts and the necessity for a new
societal order Albrecht states the
certainty that upon the remnants will
rise a quote new city adjusted to new
ways of life Beirut declares more
concretely that Warsaw quote must be
given the characteristic features of the
new epoch of true humanism the epoch of
the rights of working man end quote the
insistence of town planners to restore
the characteristic idiosyncrasies of the
old town while conforming to a larger
development plan was but a bullet point
on the litany of the party mandate such
a condition may be the result of a
certain problem of legitimacy on the
ground as it were the occupation of
poland by both the nazis and Asil viet's
first the interwar government
of Poland into a London exile however
this government had a presence in the
occupied state which comprised of a
resistance army and a fully functioning
under ground state that contained all
the components of sovereign government
to the fully fully functioning judicial
system civil service and programs that
continue to host educational and
cultural activities despite Nazi efforts
to eliminate them when Sylvia forces
entered polish territory in pursuit of
retreating Germans they too established
a resistance army and revived the Polish
workers party with its Intendant
bureaucracy the heads of this party
mostly trained in Moscow word odds with
the Exile government in London concern
over the situation of two distinct and
ideologically divergent polish
governments soon settled out and larger
perceived allied spirit of solidarity
but concerns of legitimacy were not
unfounded and there's a host of State
Department documents which contain
corroborating evidence of concern about
how the government was to be parceled
out the brief period of Allied
occupation after the war had come to an
end as by 1948 by then most of the the
communists had control over most of the
government and in turn over most aspects
of the society presence of these two
opposed foreign friends of resistance
during the occupation and liberation of
Poland would further complicate the
attempts of the socialist state to gain
credible Authority and implementing its
structural policies as a result of this
tentative grip on power the new state
would turn to architectural restoration
and industrial development to aid in
these consolidation efforts and what
we're seeing here is the reconstructed
walls of the old town which were buried
essentially under the buildings from
seventeenth eighteenth and nineteenth
centuries as the fortifications were no
longer needed and so it's interesting
that in this 1956 test text we have a
nice high pearly colored distinct shade
of red I don't you know I think that's
necessarily coincidental the foreign
publications considered i'll provide a
unifying cohesive gloss to polish
socialism a gloss which conceals the
conflicts what's conceals the conflicts
within governance as to the mechanism
shape and color of socialism in poland
deeper investigation of this in relation
to modernizing and restoration will
provide insight that made for a
speculation at the beginning of this
talk the potential of resistance
Varian guys' by distinct segments of the
society is beyond the scope here but I
posed the question in order to begin the
consideration of how representations
plans and strategies can be marshaled in
double ways to both impose and resist
within the same condition and it's
interesting that these texts all of them
in a recall history in a very specific
and certain way yet at the same time
continually recycle the photographic
images juxtapositions of heavy industry
in relation to monumental forums and so
if you were to take these four texts and
of apart you'd see that the same
photographs appear the same that if
spreads start to appear but always kind
of repositioned through text so they're
always bundled with that the outline of
historic Warsaw May on the surface
appear to contradict the development
aesthetic of the high modernist
silhouette of Brasilia whose outline is
also historically protected as
significant and the ease of situating
them as opposition's both ideologically
and aesthetically is offered by such
frame however with Warsaw the sheer
weight of devastation and the seemingly
false facades of reproduction the lie
and interesting and productive narrative
as illuminated through the sequence of
texts whose continual repress entation
of reconstruction through the recycling
of photographs the transcription of
texts amplifying subsuming of parting
rhetoric through bureaucratic minutiae
in a situation of varying agents tell
not the history is not tell not the
history of warsaw's reconstruction but I
believe its multifarious recomposition
thank
right thank you thank you to the
organizers thank you to Louise with the
introduction and now i'm not going to
sing my way through this presentation
it's amazing what they can found in
google you can run but you can't hide
okay sorry donut sound like continuous
ington Oscar speech but also need to
acknowledge the support of the National
Research Foundation of South Africa that
made this research possible okay by the
time the nationalist party came to power
in 1948 the architectural language
associated with Afrikaner nationalism
had been clearly articulated borrowing
bread from the strip classicism of the
1930s and from certain vernacular
African traditions it aimed to construct
a fox at high tech teague a people's
architecture for the materia nation as a
concrete manifestation of political
aspirations at a time in Africana
nationalism was asserting itself for
that high tech te vas made a claim for
the authenticity of the modern africanos
uniquely african origins and they
consequent right to sovereign nation
hood the decorative programs
commissioned for these buildings in turn
reinforced the clumsy tropes of
political authenticity and belonging
implicit in the architectural vocabulary
the quintessential example of the style
with head of mood head of mood acts
foraker monument was inaugurated in 1949
following so close on the heels of the
National Party victory it gave literal
expression to the abstractions of
politics and nation-building and
appeared to set the tone for the future
architectural projects of the africana
state by the time of the sweater
uprisings in 1976 however this language
had shifted considerably on the back of
an ever strengthening economy and
burgeoning industrialization
state-sponsored building projects had
proliferated in the urban centers but
now invariably designed in a style that
embraced the concrete and glass
modernity of the post-second World War
international style with
that bordered on the messianic the
decorative programs commissioned for
these buildings are also increasingly
and insistently abstract from monolithic
Civic Center's and at provincial
administration buildings to theater
complexes airports and data reformed
churches the overwhelming if often
inappropriate architectural message of
the 1960's was a government that had
arrived and whose claims to progress and
return modernity were unassailable as
suggested in this paper that the
self-conscious embrace of modernity is
more than merely a response to the
nationalist government's program of
modernization and urbanization it is
also implicitly linked to the
construction of a particularly imaginary
of white afrikaner nationhood large
scale buildings promoted the imaginary
of modernity and success while the
self-consciously abstract art that
populated them further reinforced the
africana nation's sophisticated European
values this I argue has profound
implications for notions of what
constituted africana high culture and
the way in which it was officially
mediated in architectural terms at the
height of the part 8 as Africa the
nationalism matured as a social and
political horse in the 1930s its social
imaginary was increasingly associated
with what Dan bar moody identifies as
the civil religion of the African of
fork the articles of faith of this
religion were strict Calvinism single
medium matter tank education racial
segregation the betterment of poor
afrikaners and ultimately the
establishment of a republic in cultural
terms the civil religion was expressed
primarily in two ways first in the
valorisation of the majestic beauty of
virgin landscape or promised land which
had been paid for in blood by the
righteousness and heroism of the fur
trekkers and second in the imaginative
reconstruction of the history of the fur
trekkers whose selflessness and brave
sacrifice errs laid the africanus
through the wilderness to this promised
land the inauguration of the frigerator
monument in 1949 was thus the
realization of a long-cherished desire
to have a permanent and highly visible
shrine to the firt records
and was there for an event of
considerable cultural and political
significance the monument is also the
crowning achievement of the notion of
folks at hitech Teague whose most
vociferous champion was the architect
had a move deck the first fully
articulated example exemplar of the
ideas that would inform the monument is
moot legs mariinsky library on the
university of pretoria campus university
had became an Afrikaans language
institution in 1930 and mood lay across
the chairperson of the university
counsel at the time of the library's
Commission the project does afforded him
a prestigious platform from which to
promote his ideas of fort architect heed
the library's bettered granite walls
arising from the arroz de gate base
create an impression of monumentality
while the zigzag stone course at the top
of the building later to be repeated on
the frigerator monument is a direct
reference to the outer walls of great
zimbabwe the zigzag ubiquitous and
endearing signifier of Africa is
repeated on the spandrel windows sorry
on the spandrels spandrel panels and
window panes other direct quotations
include larry leafs of the zimbabwe bird
on the entrance architrave and baboons
above the entrance itself which is a
motif taken from a carved soapstone dish
that was found in the ruins as with the
fur tracker monument this highly
selective reading of an African
vernacular is subsumed within the
streamlined modernity of overall design
quietly promoting the notion of the
authenticity of the modern africanus
claimed to African origins and the
consequent right to its bounty in the
context of Afrikaans language
institution known for its nationalist
sympathies this was provocative staff
indeed and would be amply vindicated by
the Nationals party's victory in 1948 by
the time of the Sarita uprisings in 1976
however false architected had assumed a
very different guys all their rhetorical
statements drawing on the established
reps of the civil religion never
entirely disappeared after the
establishment of the Republic in 1961 a
strident and self-conscious middle
he was unequivocally associated with the
appearances of the various apparatuses
of state that between the birth of the
africana national state in 1948 and the
political watershed of 1976 that would
ultimately destabilize it a significant
shift occurred from from a
backward-looking blood and soil
regionalism to a sophisticated
internationalist rhetoric that was more
in tune with the aspirations of a modern
nation state theories of nationalism are
instructive here as Anderson Gallner and
others have shown something of a paradox
is discernible in the construction of
new nationalisms while nations are by
definition relatively recent constructs
this object of modernity is underscored
by a subjective sense of antiquity homi
bhabha refers to this phenomenon as a
double time of the nation in which the
nation is some old tent in which the
nation simultaneously posits ancient
origins as well as a progressive
futurity imagined past gives it
legitimacy while a forward-looking
modernity enables it to take its
rightful place as a viable entity within
a community of nations lawrence joao
vale shows how similar impulses may be
discerned in architectural terms first
in the need of the sponsoring regime to
reassert a sub-national identity by
equating its ethnic heritage with the
national second it's need to extend this
identity into the international realm by
means of some kind of noteworthy
modernity and third the need to develop
the personal identity of the client or
designer certainly all three of these
elements are abundantly present in mood
takes four Forks architect heed not only
do they conflate the africanus at
national identity with the broader
African identity by means of the use of
regional materials and iconographic
references but do you say within a
self-consciously modernist style thus in
turn establishes mudak as the
quintessential folks at high tech or
where people's architect whose
engagement on any subsequent projects
would carry the turn of highest moral
credibility nonetheless mood X emphasis
on or toxin in heroic histories
fundamentally backward-looking its
nationalist rhetoric relying heavily on
notions of subject of antiquity within a
decade the Afrikaner nationalism
Nationalist government now firmly in
power the emphasis could shift to a
celebration of the offeree of the
Afrikaner nations object of modernity
examples abound particularly in the
proliferation during 1950s and 60s of
state-sponsored public buildings in
pretoria the center of the nationalist
government civil service all of which
reject the rhetorical traps of mudark
and forks architected in favor of an
assertive modernity two aspects of the
historical record are pertinent here
first the establishment of school of
architecture at the University of
Pretoria in 1943 whose first graduates
are qualified by 1948 and second the
staging of the Brazil builds exhibition
in New York also in 1943 for the
emerging generation of Africana
architects Brazil builds provided a
compelling reference point for the use
of architecture within a program of
national modernization indeed say
immediate and pervasive was the
Brazilian influence that sir nikolaus
pevsner after touring South Africa in
1953 with famous route famously referred
to quote the unknown existence of a
little Brazil in the Commonwealth and
prepped the first of the Brazil inspired
buildings the meat board building in
Pretoria is a case in point designed by
the german-born architect helmet staff
who had joined the staff of the Pretoria
school of architecture in 1943 this
building is a scaled-down transcription
of the famous Ministry of Education
Health in Rio raised on Pilates with
fins on a vertical grid to accommodate
flexible interior partitioning and
articulated roofs cape and an adjustable
brisa lay the meat board in effect
issued a clarion call to the public
works department young architects and
national ideologues alike to imagine a
new kind of folks at high tech tea for
the capital when his confident embrace
of a progressive future would allow the
ever strengthening of Ricardo nation to
its cert to assert itself on an
international stage the Pretoria school
of architecture was quick to heed the
school throughout the 1950s the dominant
idiom on the campus was Brazilian
featuring elaborately sculptural
buildings with peaceful a glazed tiles
and mosaics replacing applied
designed exclusively by africana
architects the buildings on the campus
became an important testing ground for
architectural ideas that would soon
become synonymous with the capital the
so-called pretoria regionalism that
spread rapidly throughout the burgeoning
city and its suburbs in effect pretoria
regionalism as the style of choice for
the public works department in time
became de facto a new folks architected
the building that irrevocably put the
stamp of official sanction on pretoria
regionalism with the transvaal
provincial administration building
occupying an entire city block this was
the largest official public Commission
of the decade completed in the year
after the establishment of the Republic
it certainly set a new standard in Civic
architecture one that would be widely
emulated in South Africa's rapidly
expanding towns and cities like the meat
board building the transvaal provincial
administration building reiterates the
lessons of Rio de Janeiro but yeah
exercised on a monumental scale balanced
in details in its details by restraint
and rationality designed by a team led
by Al mayadeen was then the professor of
architecture at the University of
Pretoria it dominated the city center
the implacable rhythm of its facade
forming a dramatic backdrop for the
city's historical buildings not least
the wrath saw is the point of this
building here which was the assembly
hall of Paul Krugers brewery public
government with hindsight it is
impossible not to interpret this
jackster position of the old and the new
administrative centers of the brewery
publix as a grand triumphal gesture in
the mode of barbers double time the
Nationalist government in effect
claiming legitimacy through the imagined
inevitability of history the building's
symbolic importance was further
consolidated by the inclusion of an
extensive decorative program with
celebrated artists being commissioned to
produce work in a decidedly modernist
idiom these include Alexis pill is this
mural discovery and tapestry designed by
BTC a partner entitled woman and cecily
sashes mosaic
all of which are careful balance between
figuration and abstraction by the latter
half of the 1960's public architecture
shows a dramatic stylistic shift towards
brutalism more and more these monumental
structures be taken the arrogant trans
ilysm of the apartheid state with
clearly demarcated entrances and public
areas for whites and non-whites the
former inevitably on a more considered
and lavish scale than the latter the
decorative programs associated with
these buildings also became increasingly
abstract and sophisticated stridently
proclaiming the flawed ideal of an up to
date white nation in africa significant
examples include the a chief of wood
building the home of the provincial
administration of the orange free state
in the city of bloom from town which
features a 12-story high stained glass
facade by the artist the oven phenomena
and a large mural by Betty Elia bad note
featuring the development of the orange
free state the overriding concern with
the kind of decorative abstraction that
characterizes both the building and its
decorative program becomes the necessary
condition for other public commissions
at the time notably the monumental
monumentally sculptural de Soleil and
various murals and other decorative
elements for the international terminal
of Yang's matts airport in Johannesburg
completed in 1972 the self-conscious
celebration of modernity that informs
the a chief of wood building and its
decorative program is interesting in
terms of the social imaginary that it
constructs particularly in view of the
fact that it was completed at a time
when the National Party was enjoying its
strongest support the March 1990s are
even March 1966 election in which
National Party won overwhelming majority
of hundred and 26 seats effectively
rendered South Africa a single-party
state and the prime minister a chief
votes political and economic agenda had
been largely fulfilled by the time he
was assassinated in September 1966 in a
building named for the infamous
architect of apartheid as he's known
this building clearly asserts that while
the prime minister may be dead
his vision of economic prosperity and
the guidance of white supremacist
culture continues to flourish it is
important to note that unlike mood bag
the architects producing this officially
sanctioned modern architecture in the
1960s and 70s were not all afrikaners
nor were they necessarily African the
Nationalists indeed sir abstract and
internationalist are their designs that
it seems in retrospect that they were
wholly unmoved by or wilfully oblivious
of the political turbulence of their age
while the fact that they achieved
official recognition in the form of
highly visible public commissions does
not necessarily make them complicit with
the net Nationals project it nonetheless
points to a paradigm attic shift on the
part of the africana cultural elite a
sophistication was increasingly bling
valued above sentiment and optimistic
future over a troubled past this has to
be understood in relation to changing
ideological values in the two decades
after 1948 the period immediately
following the 1948 victory was dominated
by the consolidation of the nationalist
parties ideological principles by the
1960s however this had largely been
achieved africanos were now firmly in
control of all organs of state and the
generation that had come to political
maturity was sufficiently empowered to
embrace new constructs of what it meant
to be in Africana indeed throughout the
1960s the notion of the modern nation
was aggressively promoted against a
backdrop of increasing isolationism the
draconian policies of the state were
justified in terms of white afrikaner
racial and cultural supremacy with a
part 8 as its ideological cornerstone
the Afrikaner middle class also grew
exponentially a function both of
urbanization and of policies that
privileged whites in general and
africanos in particular the generation
of urban africanus that came to maturity
in the 1960s and 70s that had a
profoundly different awareness of itself
and of its place in the world net which
had informed its parents and
grandparents indeed young middle-class
africanus in the 1960s and early 70s
riding the crest of an economic boom and
living the state that aggressively and
jealously promoted
well being could enjoy a prosperity and
concomitant sense of confidence and
cultural superiority that would have
been unimaginable for their parents
generation an important aspect of the
debate that cannot be overlooked here is
the ideological schism between the
circled foot lifter or enlightened and
the furred kilometer or reactionary
africanus that occurred within the
africana elite during the 1960's
interestingly the catalyst for this
rapture was cultural rather than
political in May 1964 the writer 18
LaRue was awarded the South African
academy of arts and sciences highest
award for literature for his
controversial novel seven days of the
Silverstein's at once a parody of the
creation and a parable of the failure of
the Nationals project the controversy
that it provoked raised profound
questions about what constituted the
acceptable limits of Africana culture
although storage nationalist LaRue was a
member of the literary group the sister
Herzl that sixty years we took up a
politic it upon themselves to revitalize
Afrikaans culture oh sorry Afrikaans
literature this was achieved both in
their engagement with themes that were
anathema to the existing canon as well
as in the experiments with form while
there is no direct equivalent to the
Sisterhood's in terms of the South
African visual arts or architecture of
the period the group Mandela's paved the
way for new forms of cultural expression
the rise of abstraction as the dominant
language both of high art and official
architecture at this time is part of the
same cultural imaginary it must be
ascribed to the coming of age of a
younger generation of farruko
enlightened africanus whose identity was
emphatically urban rather than rural and
whose middle-class aspirations and
values were well served by the
abstractions of high modernism the shift
from the backward looking and
sentimental figure to tradition too
self-conscious modernity in less than
two decades is an astonishing turn
around and speaks volumes about the
changing notions of the of the africana
nation and its aspirations I think it is
fair to say that this new abstract
language
by the 1970s become entrenched as part
of the high culture sanctioned by the
nationalist government and in that way
canonical this in turn raises
interesting questions questions about
the relationship between the cannon and
power and about what gets valued in
particular social and political contexts
and why in the post 1994 context it also
raises questions about the ways in which
the nation is imagined and constructed
in visual terms and how this in turn is
sanctioned by the state the return to
literalism in the figurative tradition
often predicated on notions of heroism
and triumph over suffering which have
seen in post-apartheid public buildings
and should give us some pause for
thought given the recent and odious
example of Africana nationalism with all
its smug assumptions of moral and
cultural sapir superiority this begs the
question what is the emergent Canon and
whose interests to its embedded values
serve as Michael billig notes if the
future remains uncertain we know the
past history of nationalism and that
should be sufficient to encourage a
habit of watchful suspicion thank
first of course i have to thank these
speakers for all these great papers it's
always the job of the person sitting in
the seat i'm sitting to somehow disagree
with them and critique them and tell
them what's wrong with their papers at
least i think that's part of the job and
in this case it was particularly
difficult because there had to force
myself to find some disagreements but
luckily for you i found some i also
found some common themes which is why
maybe common themes at all these or
let's call them anxieties it all these
papers share which is maybe a good way
to begin one unspoken sort of theme and
a catalyst of a lot of the changes that
not only the papers of this session but
i think the conference as a whole is
trying to trace or come to grip griffith
is actually the subject of war war of
course not thought of as a destructive
or solely as a destructive presence in
the production of architecture but
actually is a very very incredibly
powerful productive force which we saw
in two papers at least today because it
both well the current explanation goes
that of course when war starts
architecture stops but nothing like that
actually happens and instead our picture
becomes other things and architecture
our war paves the way for architectural
production usually so i'd like for at
least two of you or potentially three of
you to discuss that subject or how you
see ur eyes it or how it's a how it's a
problem you have to deal with of course
the other very extremely important theme
and arguably the most important
dimension within architecture within
which actually the state becomes
manifests in a way that's not always
obvious is the subject of restoration
and reconstruction but primarily I think
restoration because we've seen many
papers in which or we usually tend to
think of the state's presence in in ways
that are tie its presence to a sort of
first of all monumental statements
architecture and usually quote unquote
progressive statements within
architectural terms that's usually how
we see the state manifesting itself
monumentally but it actually a very
quiet presence of the state throughout
this whole period and maybe it's
sometimes not so quiet as you show it as
as in see on showed its through the
restoration of things and remaking it
things and sometimes it's a kind of
decisively conservative move but
actually it's it's it's it's not as ash
holes a show there's not always an
opposition with sort of modernists
ideals in fact it's a it's a crucial
component of modernist practice so I'd
like for you to talk about that maybe a
little bit too and now i think the the
main subject or subtext that to all the
papers three of them is that in every
case scenario that we've seen everybody
who's writing about whether it's south
africa well to some extent i guess war
so it but particularly think Franco's
Spain arrives at these subjects with a
well or these rather these subjects
arrive to the research it was a very
very will equip equipped with kind of a
very dense layers of explanations of
what not only what happened during these
periods but also about what the ideology
behind whether incoherent or not why the
ideology was behind these periods or
what happened politically in these
periods and I think a subject that
everyone is grappling with is primarily
parsing how architecture complicates
that relationship because I really
believe it does of course a classic way
to deal with this is to say that
architecture is or provides ideology
with a certain language usually
monumental language or that it masks
things or the clothes things or that it
but it always stands in a very unstable
very promiscuous relationship with
ideology but in cases like these where
we already have a very sometimes very
sophisticated sometimes not but always
very strong and very well established
literature that explains this to us
before we get to the actual
architectural evidence so to speak it's
always a very difficult problem because
nobody really is going to stand here or
nobody in their right
unusual is gonna stand here and say that
well Park I maybe wasn't that bad you
know nobody's gonna start defending that
we all agree more or less on aesthetic
and moral terms about the kind of wrong
that was same thing with Franco and
maybe not so much for war so because I'm
assuming this is a relatively pink
audience being ideologically speaking so
deep in our pink hearts we all have some
kind of nostalgia for those kinds of you
know very distant socialist scenarios
which were usually very far removed from
maybe that's why we like them so much
but in any case it maybe that's a little
more debatable but there's a set script
and then there's many layers within or
many ways many modes in which
architecture interacts with that so I
wonder we could start talking about all
that just one by one application ash
goes first now I'm going to be a state
the state declares that ash speaks later
but it isn't my fascists I'd have to
come now out so okay and attempting it
may be position in the you're dense
layering yes presented I mean the
positioning of restoration is in
opposition of modernism you always going
to have to produce one in order to
refute it right in order to legitimize
the motor is in project you have to get
refute the fact that everyone's backward
or peasants or whatever you and more
often than not coming from a what we
would call a provincial or parochial
part of the United States you know we've
always been kind of couched as a means
of you know we need to be we need to
present you know that which is
traditional that which is it needs to be
preserved protected from the modernist
project in order to legitimize the
modernist project so it's it's always a
complicated process because and
especially why I think Warsaw is
insightful is that the two were so
readily kind of put in the mix in order
to legitimize the socialist project and
then in the context to war you know
Poland's kind of you
position is still being somewhat of a
hinged state from you know the West to
you know the USSR I mean especially if
you look at an organization like UNESCO
which I mean the society did not come
into that 2053 I spoke a war of the both
of the hot and the cold lair yeah I'm
speaking to the cool the Cold War and so
you know the idea that you know Warsaw
can being this hinge state buffer state
for any number of reasons that it
started to actually export its its
restoration knowledge you know to not
only Eastern Bloc but also to other
parts of the world and so I think it's
it's the war is also being productive
gender & of holding to that tradition in
some way like because it means to
preserve that tradition as means to then
export it it then became somewhat
plausible but also to with in Poland
itself the problem of because Warsaw
gain such dominance as kind of been the
president would say this you know it's
worse on the nation or some in this kind
of equation of the two you know that the
rest of the country was somewhat mind
for artifacts to reconstitute or saw and
so there's those problems as well and so
it's not as easy as just saying I don't
know if that answered any or all of your
questions yes there are I think what I
can respond to you know it's not it's
not obvious in my paper but the war the
idea war is omnipresent africana
nationalism as an ideology was born on
the back of the South African War and
the indignities and you know the sort of
attempts to crash the burn a shin that
happened in that horn sort of women and
children being interned in concentration
camps and so on and the the history of
that war carcery long shadows deep into
the 20th century and in a sense this the
kind of need to mobilize the fork in a
sense was partly on a kind of you know
one hand to take ownership to to take
possession of the promised land but also
on the kind of never
in principle you know that we would
never be a people that are like this
again and hence the kind of force
architected ideas in the 1940s but I
think what's interesting is that the
idea of war you know as the the shadows
of the concentration camps start
receding in the shadows of the South
African War start receding another war
tax over and then of course is the
ideological war you know so in effect
the Afrikaner government was a
government at war war it was an
illegitimate government at war to
protect its status you know from the
minitor took occupancy in 1948 until
minute it was booted out in 1994 it was
affected we were effectively a country
at war itself you know it was it kind of
was it a civil war that never happened
and in a sense this kind of a sort of
grand rhetorical statements of public
space and public building and public art
of the kind of a papering over that it's
a kind of a that creates this this kind
of these illusions and lacuna you know
and interpolate every single subject
that looks at them well I would like to
introduce an another reflection out
restoration because it's an art topic
that is growing and growing and and
having more importance now in in the
world of architecture and restoration
sometimes is presenting or so is that so
it as a technical operation at and it is
because if you'd if you don't restore a
monument sometimes the moment pulled up
okay but if you consider the history of
restoration from the beginning until
nowadays a will realize that is also and
this is more important a cultural
process and that the restoration speaks
more about the restorer than they object
because when you restore you a national
market and choose a monument and decide
to rebuild or to restore normally store
Royson a specific reason and it's
happened in Spain and the Queen secures
also is very important because a as
saying this now is happening for us
because I have to say that I forget to
mention that my research my research is
supported by the national phone and I am
a member of national equipment in Spain
and we are doing a national research
about the restoration under a first
franchisee the cadet the cadets of
thirties forties and fifties and we
discover that the main important
buildings in Spain that we have studied
as middle-aged the architecture has been
restored by Fernando chocobo idea
Alejandro veyron and we have to change
the history of architecture so we have 2
Chainz also what were what we know about
the stud buildings and this is also in
very very important and we have to study
also why did they did did they choose
these monuments because they something
is a political real reason Santana's an
historical reason santa is an
ideological reason so this is important
this is a emergency topic I think that
we have to consider and to end my
reflection and even nowadays the
restoration is using as an ideological
instrument to change history because if
you for instance one nation that
attracts me quite a lot a doctrine
Germany now in Germany they are
resistant they are restoring the
monuments changing the history because
some buildings that were built in the
70s now they are pulling down with a
quite a lot of comments and polemics but
because these buildings are there
reminds of
de a Republican Democratic ali mahdi
register so they are using the
restoration to change the history and
this is more even in a about all
interested Princeton with the
reconstruction of the crown kill head
and the elimination of the buildings
coming from their seventies so what
happens I think that really relates a
very important theme and we we should
think about it make a brief comment on
that and in a sense the opposite sort of
things happening in South Africa at the
moment that is kind of the opposite of
restoration is this kind of demolition
by neglect you know a lot of the
buildings that are shared like the
transvaal provincial administration
government for building for example it's
just literally starting to fall apart
you know a lot of the bronze cladding
has been stripped off it's just it's
just neglected and you know as he says
it's in a way that's also sort of
opposite of what you're saying it sort
of it's sort of a passive way of
changing issue of course another
interesting common thread was the ways
in which state sponsored narratives or
as they are mediated through
architecture negotiate the boundaries
between national and global right in
every case I think there was a lot of
projection for a state image was
constructed through architecture several
different kinds of architecture and
several kinds of operations through
architecture but you pointed out in the
paper about Spain that there was a
disjunction for example about actually
there was a disjunction not just I would
say not toward the end necessarily just
toward the end but I guess throughout
the period that your mapping of a what
was projected in the home front so to
speak and what was projected abroad and
they were actually rather different
images you spoke with eco spoke about a
sort of desire to or aspiration toward
certain kind of cosmopolitanism which is
very of course very evident in the
the absorption of certain very specific
kinds of iconography and ash you spoke
it's interesting because of course you
have shown for sources which are for
kind of polished published sources that
translated or importantly sources yeah
so of course who wear those books really
published for write their books not
really necessarily for the home front
and so in both in all cases I wonder if
we could speak a little bit about this
subject and particularly because tracing
be the limits of the reception of
architecture is very problematic very
difficult because of course it takes on
so many different cultural other
cultural forms it depends you could
almost say another kind of kinds of
cultural forms and media apparatuses
which are sometimes related to the State
apparatuses and sometimes not so I
wonder if we could talk about this a
little bit for himself in in Spain the
end of the 50s was very surprising
because Franco system became some kind
of schizophrenic inside you read the
papers on you see or you see the things
the documentary fills the image inside
the country is what close traditionalism
and it's there's no motor out there is
no modern architecture but the same
state when they have to take artists
outside Spain they choose the more
tomorrow and modern artists for instance
Tapia Sarah Emmanuel viola and it was
something strange because these people
couldn't show a her their paintings in
Spain but they decide to take a damn BNI
Olivia so it's really something skip of
League I think we try to die no miro
right
afrikaner nationalism and folks
capitalism in end of the construction of
capital besides an anecdote which I
think really answers your comment quite
nicely he's he sort of speaks of the
Afrikaner poet ranking plating bath it
was hugely controversial in his day not
least because he he married a colored
woman and you know in terms of the
immorality act at the time that was not
allowed he actually had to need the
country but you know played on
dragonback hood rail against the
africana on stage and the way that I
mera describes a decision a year would
all these sort of these sort of well
turned out africana bushwa people
sitting in these you know sort of
magnificent new theaters that had been
designed specifically for them being
railed against you know but in a sense
they said that and I think it points to
this fundamental it's a kind of a
paradox in a way that on the one hand
you've got this very determined and very
self-conscious embrace of modernity and
internationalism and cosmopolitanism and
yet it's a society that is so
inward-looking and so close-minded and
so you know the ideological control
exerted by the prudent one for example
which was this kind of secretive
organization that shadow government and
that ultimately would enable people to
get the commissions for these projects
and so on so these are the eyes that's
their kind of tension between the
international image and the effect of
the culture and the surface I think you
know to speak to the for publications
first of all to limit you know terms of
from a sheer research and of language
access right I mean and to deal with
publications that did make it into
English as a word of it not only appeal
to know very large you know expat
community that wears in the United
States and London and other parts of
Europe and from from Poland but it's
also you start to see him where the univ
things get some soon what the
underground state is mentioned in the
you know the Warsaw lives again from 46
right so you still have this kind of
collaborative effort and so the
acknowledgments of the interwar
governments where you know as has been a
line you know communism had been
outlawed you know and so it's they're
still acknowledging those in relation
because they don't know how the Cold
War's honest it hasn't really started
yet so things haven't really shaken out
so 49 you know it's very much a
Stalinist kind of rhetoric of Ron and
you know 56 it's riding into cruise
ships thaw we're not quite sure and then
64 it's more of a legitimizing of the
socialist project abroad as well as a
home let me just say you know throughout
the photo spreads its you know the kind
of far we've come look at how far away
the band's the plan has worked yes there
were mistakes that but it you know the
idea that it was still you know in
appeal to the to the larger to the
larger international polish community as
well as the larger international
community itself that you know it was a
system that was in place and working
right and so like it or not and so yeah
I mean there is that romance that we all
the pink audience you know so it is you
know interesting to see that because I
think where you start to see things
going to fall below the tax fall between
more productive I think in those texts
that get polished and in their
limitation rather than
who said blood and also the problems and
as in an earlier panel as an opponent
out from the earlier Poland panel that
it wasn't necessarily a cohesive
socialist kind of system I mean there
was conflict especially in the early
years but what was the polish road to
socialism as we're immolation scholars
and so how does that shake out okay so
I've been rambling enough I think we can
open this to the audience we have five
minutes so
the library that you showed pretoria
library in the beginning there were
references to different cultural styles
you mentioned to what extent do you
think those were those cause definitions
of tradition or culture were invention
of the State apparatuses themselves I
asked that because I know that the most
ingenious instrument of control during
British colonial period in South Africa
as well as Equatorial Africa was not
institution and sorry not territorial
segregation but institutional
segregation so inventing different ideas
of cultural try tradition you know for
the African native population and then
coming up with set of laws to control
that so the population can exist in the
city you're mixed in with the whites but
they are institutionally there are
separate set of laws for them so
institutionally they are segregated and
that's been where the brunt of power was
felt you know the most to what extent
that tradition continues in the
Afrikaner state well I think whether you
talk about the Mariinsky library the
yeah it's an interesting situation
obviously that being having being built
in the 1930s it's all very much in the
time when the administration is largely
sort of British imperialist and africana
nationalism desperately trying to assert
its presence so the appropriation there
of African of a kind of an African idiom
it has a very distinct kind of
ideological message it's trying to sort
of claim a sense of the African as
belonging so it's quite ironic in a way
because on the one hand is that that
complete rejection of sort of black
indigenous culture and the need you know
to kind of see it as being separate this
is also the time in the 1930s that be
the sort of form of ethnographies being
practice particularly in Africana
institutions called for peek under and
the essential principle of Falkirk under
was that races are culturally
fundamentally different you know that
have different kind of ethnos and the
white afrikaner has a sort of different
and of course superior if not to black
South Africans but over there is that
kind of sense it's similar in a sense to
what what you're saying with a kind of a
kind of an ideological as well as of the
African culture ethnic culture that's
being referred to is invention of the
state itself I mean there is no such
thing as that traditional absolutely
sure that absolutely is completely an
invention state because it's a state
trying to claim a certain kind of
authenticity it's trying to say that we
are African and I think what is
interesting about that is that it in
fact on the way that's ironically quite
forward-looking because this is at a
time where popular scholarship on Great
Zimbabwe was saying that it couldn't
possibly been built by black people you
know there was built by Phoenicians and
you know and so people like move deck
and evers in fact they were of the
confirmed opinion that it had infected
they did come from local cultures and
that that sort of conflation Lynn of
sort of Africana with an African
identity becomes absolutely an
ideological construction part of that
kind of emerging state apparatus but
it's not an apparatus yet because of
course it's not even africana state
thank you I just wanted to congratulate
everybody on the panel for really
amazing presentations and my questions
really about methodology and in thinking
about your historiography I mean were
you that the dates that you picked I
thought it was quite interesting to see
the way each of you tried to frame your
papers in relationship to what Louise
was mentioning at the beginning these
kind of existing interpretations of
history and if the conference is about
architecture and this state certainly
there are different kind of temporal
frameworks that are imposed on a history
of architecture in the history of the
state and and it's it's interesting when
political events become the kind of
organizing framework for understanding
architectural history one wonders
whether that is the most it's certainly
necessary sometimes but whether it's the
most productive and in the case of each
of your presentations I thought that
maybe a more expanded framework is I
thought that all of them were somehow
very much on the state as a history of
the state as a kind of chronology and I
was wondering whether there might not be
a way of opening that up a little bit
more by by contrasting maybe in the end
thinking of homi bhabha this notion of
dual times or multiple times and so on
architecture i was thinking of
particularly for instance in a sentient
I mean that would be able to comment on
e to him but maybe just to make it brief
rest and soon in your presentation on
where you gave the sense of a radical
break between the Republic's work on
preservation and restoration and
Franco's government work on restoration
that notion of a radical break which was
of course what Franco wanted that
historiography of radical break was was
Franco wanted and you very rightly
pointed out the fact that local auto
service and Martel was they were pushed
out a zonal architects but of course the
other four out of the six zonal
architects in Spain remained and POW in
place working
throughout the throughout both both
governments so there might be ways in
which these narratives can be in a sense
complicated and and that the notion of
the state apparatus might have a temper
ality that is different from political
regimes and that might have a bearing on
architectural history I you know I so I
was wondering how you might be able to
kind of comment on the frames that you
picked because it seems like the
documents that we work on already gently
predispose us towards a kind of
narrative now okay well i found very
interesting the the comments on the idea
of making reflection about maternal
emitter mythology methodology and the
point is the documentation i was i was
using in that moment of my research so
because all your worlds about day what
happened with the other architects i
know i know very well what happen
because we are working about him now but
the progress that i don't have enough
time to do it so i decided to use the
reviews awesome the way to make my
reflection of this this problem know and
I and so I decided to use the reviews
and I find the exhibitions and I
realized that there's something
interesting in this exhibition because
this confront this idea of confront the
Spanish pavilion of the Republican day
on the provision of a 90 in the first
exhibition is something that appears in
my mind I'd say there should be a
connection between Eddie's because they
ID a general idea of the importance of
the of the Republic of the Second
Republic it could in a pair he couldn't
disappear so quickly no so when the
point is that i use the review but as
you say in the other question about what
happened
the assistant administration of
restoration it's very important in fact
a la pelota de soie bus that you know
very well I assume as I presume Elio
poultice Torres vulvas was the man
responsible for the restoration of La of
La La Mora the Muslim Palace nalanda and
he never returned to work in alhambra so
I think that it's the one of the tragedy
of the of these decades and the other
architects Alejandro Ferland for
instance a was Maria was very close to
the republic government but after a
return to work and more or less do more
as the same things that he did
previously but in general the system was
controlled by an architect Francisco
Ethel met that he was very modern in the
way of restoration but he was very very
very close to Franco and what I would
what he did he decide to live all the
architects do what they want and son our
cadets really where they were very
inspired by this ideas of traditionally
self returned to middle-aged Princeton
manual and who Calum and arabinose
architect at I'm starina but a order as
a fernando chica idea he was a very very
important in Spanish architecture and he
was very upset quizzo mailing very
careful with the restoration so the
Spanish restoration under Franco system
is eclectic sand people the journal did
this restoration estate addictive
restoration Francisco nieta match didn't
coordinate anything but they choose the
best monuments to restore and it's very
fascinating because the same architect a
did son still it's still istic
restoration and that leads and modern
restoration so I think that is the best
evidence of the complicity I of the
decadence so that note another
complicity we end thank you to our
participants and we're back for the
keynote at six what time 630 please
thank you